you've got to actually ask yourself what
subsidies they're getting because you
hear that New York Times lot I'm not
aware of the subsidies we get personally
I we we are one of the few industries in
America that actually doesn't get to
expense its R&D we actually have periods
of time or which we have to expense rd
we don't have necessarily favorable
depreciation schedule as well to others
I don't think people would say
depreciation of fixed assets is a
subsidy actually think spurt and
personal of our tax law for all
businesses and in fact we pay higher
corporate tax rates than almost anybody
in the world today we pay severance
taxes we pay royalties we pay taxes ad
infinitum and so when people talk about
the oil companies being subsidized I
guess I just kind of wander by know
where it's coming from and why it's
coming it's not actually right